Recently, I watched this GQ video
where Justin Bieber gave an inside look
at the motorhome
he spent the height of the pandemic in.
“GQ, thank you so much for coming
to check out my tour bus.”
It's got a sauna, some
questionable art
and more closet space than
a New York City apartment.
It turns out this mammoth RV
is custom-made
and is estimated to cost
close to $2 million.
It's hard to imagine that this
penthouse on wheels
shares anything in common with this...
an entry level RV that costs $30,000...
roughly the same as a Honda Accord.
Or even this, a vintage Fleetwood Bounder
from 2001.
But look at these RVs together
and you might notice something
they do share.
It's the swooshes and swoops
and they are everywhere.
A few years ago, I moved from
New York City...
to the Berkshires.
Which is right here in western Massachusetts.
I went from the land of people
and public transit...
to the land of cows and campers.
Because of that
I've been thinking about these
ubiquitous swoops a lot...
wondering why they've lasted so long
and if they are here to stay.
To try and finally get answers
to this question...
I'm going to Elkhart, Indiana:
The RV capital of the world.
The amount of RVs produced here
amounts to about 80%
of global RV production.
Oh, there's an RV.
There's manufacturers.
There's dealers. There's campgrounds.
There's the RV History Museum,
which is where I'm going.
You heard that right.
RVs are such a part of Elkhart’s DNA
that they have a museum and Hall of Fame
dedicated to them.
[laughing] I'm so excited.
Yeah.
I am at the RV Museum Library.
Behind me are hundreds,
if not thousands of catalogs
going back to like the 1950s and beyond.
That's so cool.
It seems no matter the decade,
RVs had multicolor paid jobs
but for a long time they were
straight lines.
That is just so many straight lines.
I think a big driving factor
in a lot of that...
is technology.
Back in the 60s and 70s,
everything was straight.
Well, everything was straight
because they had tape and
they had their hands.
That's Ryan Loucks.
He designs custom exterior graphics
for Newell
a high end motorhome maker.
They’re in the same luxury category
of the company
that made Justin Bieber's bus.
We'll get to how Ryan designs these
in a second.
But first, you have the computer
come on the scene...
and the computer can cut these
perfect stripes
and curves for you.
And so, you know, you kind of
have the first layer of
printed graphics
that were cut and applied.
Next, evolution is a layer
of depth and detail
that just wasn't possible before.
This is a 1986 Fleetwood Bounder.
You might recognize it as
the RV from Breaking Bad.
Unfortunately, these stripes
didn't last long.
By the new millennium
as graphic designers got more and more
adventurous with digital tools...
straight lines were out and the swooshes
and swoops were in.
This is what the Fleetwood Bounder
looks like today.
Okay, so what exactly...
am I defining as swoosh and swoop?
Look at this. Okay.
This is a perfect example.
Okay, let me get closer.
This.
Let's see.
That is a swoosh.
That is a swoop.
Swoosh.
Swoop.
Don't fight me on that, okay?
Before I got to Elkhart
I chatted with Ryan about
his custom design process.
So while I clean up these books
and put them away...
you get to watch that.
Cut to the interview.
Generally speaking, when you're doing
paint design
you want your pin color to go first.
On a coach like this,
the whole thing would be sprayed white...
and then they'd go through
and lay their pinstripe
this kind of silvery or white edges
to the shapes.
They pull those all by hand.
And that gives you kind of
the roadmap
for everything else that happens.
In Newell's process...
they're going to go to
the next darkest color
starting with the lightest and
working towards dark
till they get to the end
which is usually the posting
or background pattern.
And ghosting is—there's kind of a color
in the background.
And then we add a layer of
clear, translucent pearl
similar to what's used in like women's
nail polish as a topcoat.
So at see through, you can see
the color behind it
but adds some sparkle
and some, you know, some interest there.
During this time they might also
add drop shadows
which makes the swoops and swirls
look almost three-dimensional.
Which is a whole art form
in and of itself.
There's no mechanical way
to add drop shadows.
That is somebody with a paint gun
almost like that guy with the pinstripe going
“I have to follow this curve perfectly...
with this black paint and not mess it up.”
These guys are basically artists...
whether they realize it about themselves or not.
I just did a crazy turnaround
because I just saw
the coolest looking RV.
Let me show you.
Isn't that so cool?
That's awesome.
When I first wrote up this pitch
I described the swooshes
as mind boggling...
atrocious and dated.
And I found a like-minded band
of anti-swooshers online
that made me feel like I was on
the right side of this debate.
But when I came across Ryan's work,
it was the first time
where I genuinely appreciated
the complexity and the detail.
And let's be honest, the fully
maximalist approach
to graphic design that these swooshes provide.
But of course, Newell’s cost $2 million
and RVs like these with fully custom
and very personal paint jobs
make up a tiny fraction of the 11.2 million
that Americans own today.
Instead of multiple painters
spending 195 hours on one coach
like Ryan's team does...
most new owners will get an RV with
an automotive-grade vinyl
that looks much more two-dimensional.
And today, there's a good chance
that that new RV owner
is going to be a lot younger
than when the swoops
first took over.
In the last 3 years, the average age
of a first time buyer
went from 41 to 32.
In large part because of the pandemic
when RV production and sales
hit record highs.
Just as fashion comes around
just as home design comes around
so does the RV industry.
And we are always looking
to stay on trend...
but also design for the masses.
That's Ashley Bontrager.
She co-founded Ember RVs in 2021.
I personally like a minimalistic approach
to design.
I want it to be linear.
We wanted to enhance the design
of our units, like the shapes
and the windows.
You know, one of the things we said is
we want to make them appear larger.
So we worked—on our designer worked on
black graphics
that just extend the length of the window
to make them appear larger from afar.
Ember makes RVs that are part of
a growing category
called overlanders.
They're designed to go
off-road and off-grid.
Looking at our RVs across this category
you start to notice that
there's no swoops.
Though some do look like
straight up tanks.
And it turns out a less swoopy look
has been percolating amongst other RV designs
the last few years.
Ultimately, I think you will see a design trend...
going more toward this
more minimal, linear graphics
in the RV space.
For every swoopy RV I saw
while driving around Elkhart
I also saw edgier designs with names like
Raptor and Avenger.
Even the iconic Bounder
has straightened up their lines for 2024.
Perhaps we're moving from
the era of swoops to daggers.
I'll let you decide if that's a good thing.
So I have some people that say
“I love the swoops and swirls.”
“They've always been there.”
“It makes me feel like home.”
“Give me tradition.”
But for every person that says that
you've got somebody that says
“I am so sick of the swoops and swirls.”
“Let's do something different.”